pour moi là si ça passe pas je considère
sérieusement à déménager parce que pour
moi mon fils et vos toute ma vie khaled
kerala est le père de william un garçon
de 10 ans nathan de traitement qui lui
permettrait de stopper la grave maladie
héréditaire qui est en train lentement
mais sûrement de le rendre aveugle lui
même est né avec un certain nombre de
des récepteurs de qui captent la lumière
ok on est né avec sa fille à chaque jour
il perd je sais pas combien la williams
est atteint de l'amaurose congénitale de
leber une maladie de l'oeil très rare
qui touche à peine 2 à 3 enfants par 100
mille naissances elle est causée par un
gène défectueux qui empêche les
photorécepteurs de la rétine de faire
correctement leur travail c'est une
maladie qui est souvent va toucher les
enfants en bas âge parfois à l'agenda en
deux ans et certains enfants perdre la
vision avant l'âge de dix ans donc assez
agressé aujourd'hui la vision de william
est de plus en plus faible les couleurs
les objets mal éclairé des mouvements
rapides tout est difficile mon ami de
natation il fait du film ici et moi je
fais ici je peux pas voir et pas comme
ça ils voient derrière ce conflit et
rend souvent
1 dans l'autre williams pourrait être
soigné avec ce traitement de pointe le
luxe turna le luxe urnes à permettrait
de remplacer les gènes défectueux par
des jeunes en pleine santé c'est un
premier traitement une première thérapie
génique qui ciblent exactement où là où
il ya la faute génétique donc on serait
capable si on est capable de remplacer
le gène en faute de corriger disons la
faute orthographe d'orthographe si on
veut dans ces conditions là et de
renverser les effets aussi le docteur
kion est l'une des rares chirurgienne
formés pour réaliser ce type
d'intervention et ça va se faire par une
chirurgie très très délicate à au fond
de l'oeil qui s'appelle une vitre et
tommy où on va aller livrer très
délicatement le produit dans une
suspension de solutions à l'arrière deux
m le problème de ce traitement c'est son
prix 1 million de dollars il est
tellement coûteux que les provinces
refuse de le rembourser étant depuis
l'automne dernier de négocier le prix à
la baisse avec le fabricant novartis ces
négociations là fonctionne très bien
lorsqu'il ya des traitements alternatifs
qui sont disponibles sont les façades
maladie pour lequel il n'y a pas de
traitements alternatifs
bercement là c'est notre pouvoir de
négociation est très réduit le luxe yona
est loin d'être cas unique aujourd'hui
le marché des maladies rares ces 10% des
ventes de produits pharmaceutiques au
pays en augmentation de 32 % par année
en moyenne il ya un modèle d'affaires
qui a été mis en place pour par les
firmes pharmaceutiques qui savent très
bien que pour ce type de médicament là
elles peuvent demander des coûts très
élevés ce modèle force les gouvernements
à faire des choix difficiles et si nous
disons non c'est c'est le gouvernement
qui va porter leurs propres de laisser
des gens mourir de maladies parce qu'on
refuse de donner accès aux médicaments
qui est disponible
québec vient de déposer sa nouvelle
politique sur les maladies rares on y
parle de formation des médecins de
dépistage demeure accès aux soins et
services mais à peine du coût des
traitements pour monsieur kerala le
temps presse et on partage l'argent en
particulier on peut pas mettre un prix
là pour
l'autonomie et l'indépendance
et la liberté d'un enfant il mérite ce
au québec une trentaine de personnes
pourrait bénéficier du luxe tourneur ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal